s'il y a bien un outil qui est
indispensable à la maison c'est un
aspirateur robot qui va venir faire le
boulot à votre place quasiment tout le
boulot on se parle donc aujourd'hui d'un
aspirateur robot qui est ici enfin
normalement qui était ici mais que bien
évidemment j'ai installé j'ai testé il à
la maison il tourne c'est bien c'est le
Dream me L20 ultra c'est donc une vidéo
qui est aujourd'hui réalisé en
partenariat avec Dream me pour vous
présenter leur dernière bébette qui est
juste là alors on connaît le principe
des aSPIRATEURS ROBOT il va passer
partout à droite à gauche il va nettoyer
le sol il va aspirer il va nettoyer avec
la serpillère mais on va toujours plus
plus loin avec plein d'options qui sont
super cool et c'est justement ce qu'on
va venir regarder aujourd'hui avec cet
aspirateur robot donc là il est
positionné dans sa base donc vous avez
votre aspirateur qui situe juste là et
sur le dessus vous allez avoir
différents boutons pour pouvoir
retourner à la base lancer l'aspiration
et compagnie et c'est intéressant parce
que sous le capot là vous avez pas mal
de choses alors déjà il vous explique
des petites choses alors il vous
l'explique en anglais vous pourrez le
mettre en français ici je l'ai en
anglais mais globalement ça va ça se
comprend soyez rassuré je vous montre
vous avez différents bacs le premier bac
c'est le bac d'eau propre où vous allez
avoir votre eau à l'intérieur vous
remontez jusqu'à un niveau maximal qui
situe juste ici donc ça c'est l'eau
propre à venir rajouter de temps en
temps vous avez ici ensuite l'eau sale
qui va falloir venir évacuer alors moi
je le mets dans les toilettes alors
après il y a ce petit truc au milieu qui
est assez intéressant vous l'ouvrez et
là vous avez deux choses la première
chose ici et bien ça va être le
détergent vous avez un détergent qui
inclut multisurface qui va venir
injecter du détergent directement pour
venir nettoyer ici vos sols on ne met
pas de détergent là-dedans parce que
c'est pas bon pour votre aspirateur
dreamy a pensé à tout vous le mettez ici
et uniquement ici et puis ensuite vous
avez une petite brossette pour venir
nettoyer votre aspi qui est pratique qui
est maline et qui est planqué surtout
juste ici donc vous voyez une fois de
plus c'est assez malin et assez bien
pensé de la part de Dream me et il y a
un autre truc qui est aussi intéressant
ça se situe juste ici alors là il vous
le monte il y a un petit bouton je
décale et là je peux venir retirer ça et
là je vais voir mon sac donc là j'ai mon
sac voyez il est vraiment pas plein il a
déjà quand même pas mal tourner donc on
en a vraiment pour longtemps et là vous
avez un deuxième sac que dreamy vous
fournit avec comme ça vous avez de quoi
voir avant de recommander d'autres
lorsqu'ils sont vraiment pleins pour
poser ensuite votre petit capot devant
voyez à une main ça se fait très
facilement on repousse le bouton voilà
comme ça c'est verrouillé c'est pratique
autre point qui est intéressant lorsque
votre aspirateur il a fini le boulot
normalement il est pas là et bien vous
vous prenez cette partie là que vous
pouvez venir retirer et que vous venez
nettoyer c'est là où il va venir
nettoyer lui directement ses serpilières
donc ça vous venez vous le nettoyez très
très facilement et comme ça vous êtes
tranquille vous utilisez la petite
brosse qu' vous ont fournie avec pour
venir nettoyer si vous avez rien d'autre
à la maison qui vous convient le Dream
mi L20 ultra a plein de techn super
intéressantes on va commencer par une
nouveauté c'est une serpillère
extensible vous voyez qu'en fait vous
avez la serpillère qui est sorti sur le
côté ça veut donc dire qu'il se prépare
lorsqu'il sait qu'il va venir nettoyer
des contours de pièces et bien il la
sort pour venir nettoyer vraiment en
profondeur les plintes très facilement
la voyer sur le côté et comme ça il va
totalement optimiser la façon dont il va
venir nettoyer les recoins de de ma
pièce alors on se parle ici bien
évidemment de plainte on se parle sur
tous les côtés on se parle également les
pieds de chaise ce qu'ils appelleent la
techno mop extend il y a un autre point
qui est super important au niveau de
cette serpilière et bien c'est que
lorsque votre aspirateur nettoie un sol
un parquet ce que vous voulez et bien la
serpilière va tourner il va venir laver
le sol sauf si vous lu dites de pas le
faire ça dans l'application et je vous
le montre dans quelques instants si par
contre vous voulez qu'il vienne nettoyer
votre sol et bien il y a un truc qui est
vachement bien lorsquil vient rencontrer
une moquette un tapis et bien c'est
qu'il vient relever sa serpilière
automatiquement et ça c'est extrêmement
malin pourquoi parce que ça évite de
venir mouiller votre moquette on veut
pas ça sert à rien et surtout ici il
vient lever plus haut par rapport à ce
qu'on avait sur les générations
précédentes on vient lever de 10,5 mm
contre 7 mm sur le l10s ultra ça évite
donc de venir mouiller vos tapis vos
moquette et de venir frotter pour rien
ici donc ça vient préserver également
vos serpillères il y a un autre point
qui est super bien ici avec vos
serpillères et bien c'est lorsque votre
aspirateur a fini de faire son boulot il
va venir nettoyer les serpilières ça il
le fera tout au long du cycle de
nettoyage mais lorsque c'est terminé il
vient et il les sèche avec de l'air
chaud directement ici ce qui fait qu'à
la fin vos serpillères sont complètement
sèches ça évite donc d'avoir une
prolifération de bactéries et ça aussi
c'est très très bien vous voyez c'est
complètement sec alors je peux vous le
montrer en prenant hop là vous voyez tac
c'est sec c'est sec il a fait le boulot
à savoir qu'ici le système de nettoyage
avec les doubles serpillères s'appelle
le duo scrub pour venir toujours mieux
nettoyer votre intérieur l'installation
se fait aussi très très facilement vous
prenez vous les enlevez et oui je sais
il me parle ça se fait très facilement
on peut venir les enlever si vous voulez
vous venir les nettoyer mais bon
globalement il y a pas besoin à
l'installation c'est facile vous les
prenez vous les positionnez très très
facilement et surtout il y a un truc qui
est extrêmement malin et je vais vous le
montrer dans quelques instant dans
l'application c'est que lorsque vous
mettez une option qui va être aspirée
uniquement et qu'on veut pas du tout de
séchage et bien on peut venir dire ici à
l'aspirateur robot si par exemple vous
avez un tapis avec des poils très très
longs et que vous voulez à aucun moment
que ça vienne frotter et bien lui il a
la capacité de venir les enlever
automatiquement et de les laisser dans
son bac qui fait qu'il va venir tourner
directement sans absolument aucune
serpillère donc ça aussi c'est un truc
qui est très malin et qui est
franchement bien vu de la part de Dream
me autre point extrêmement important
avec ce L20 ultra de Dream me c'est la
puissance d'aspiration ce qu'on attend
d'un aspirateur c'est qu'il aspire et
qu'il aspire vraiment bien ici vous avez
jusqu'à 7000 Pascal d'aspiration ça va
se passer bien évidemment par ici vous
le savez votre aspirateur qu'est-ce qui
se passe et bien ça tourne ça rabat
toutes les cochonneries ici en plus ce
qui est malin c'est que vous avez ici
une brosse en caoutchou
antienchevêtrement ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que sur certains aspirateurs
et bien vous avez une brosse avec des
espèces de poils le problème du poil et
bien c'est que lorsque vous avez des
cheveux des fils et compagnie ça vient
sans rouler autour c'est le bazar et
compagnie ici vous aurez pas ce problème
et du fait du système de caoutchou que
vous avez sur votre brosse et bien ça
vient vraiment guider toutes les
cochonneries les résidus à l'intérieur
qui vont être aspirés ici et qui vont
venir à l'intérieur et le truc qui est
également malin c'est que si vous mettez
en mode serpillère seul et vous ne
voulez pas que votre brosse en caoutchou
fasse le boulot et bien l'aspirateur va
venir la relever vous avez un relevage
automatique en mode serpillère autre
point qui est super important lorsque
vous avez un aspirateur robot ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'il reconnaisse votre
maison déjà pour différentes choses la
toute première chose c'est la
cartographie alors moi ce que j'aime
bien avec ce produit c'est qu'il a une
cartographie rapide intelligente dès le
départ qu'est-ce qui se passe lorsque
vous l'avez vous l'ouvrez vous commencez
à le configurer dans l'application SS ça
et bien il va vous dire laisse-moi
cartographier la maison vous allez voir
qu'à l'avant en plus il y a des LEDs
deux leds qui envoi franchement la
patate en terme de lumière donc il va
venir d'une reconnaître les pièces grâce
au laser ça c'est quand même très très
bien il va donc pouvoir venir ici très
facilement éviter les obstacles
connaître vos pièces cartographier votre
maison extrêmement facilement ce qui
fait que vous aurez un nettoyage
extrêmement précis va venir analyser les
pièces mettre en place une stratégie de
nettoyage et ça une fois de plus c'est
un vrai bel outil pour un nettoyage très
facile à la maison en plus de ça vous
avez un entretien qui est totalement
optimisé au niveau de votre aspirateur à
savoir que lui il va vous remonter
toutes les cochonneries qu'il a à
l'intérieur ici c'està-dire que lorsque
vous regardez là voyez vous avez un tout
petit bac avec des cochonneries là il
est totalement vide ça veut donc dire
qu'il a bien fait son boulot et qu'il a
bien aspiré si ça lorsque le nettoyage
est terminé qu'il revient à la base tout
ce qu' est à l'intérieur remonte dans un
sac que vous n'avez plus qu'à changer de
temps en temps pareil pour l'eau sale
qui repart directement il vous remet de
l'eau propre à l'intérieur est ce qui
fait qu'il est complètement prêt pour un
prochain nettoyage et ce qui est génial
c'est que vous avez un autovidage qui
peut aller jusqu'à 75 jours alors ça va
dépendre de votre mode de nettoyage si
vous mettez des modes intensifs un
moment il va venir consommer plus d'eau
mais vous pouvez aller jusqu'à 75 jours
maximum et ce qui est vraiment
intéressant ici avec dreamy qu'on trouve
pas forcément ailleurs c'est que vous
avez en plus une solution de nettoyage
qui va venir s'ajouter directement dans
votre aspirateur robot pour toujours
mieux nettoyer vos sols et autre point
qui est extrêmement important lorsque
votre aspirateur et bien a besoin de
retourner se charger ça va dépendre des
intérieurs on n pas tous les mêmes
taillees de maison si par exemple vous
avez un château à venir nettoyer ou un
très grand appartement ou une très
grande maison et bien lui il va
retourner à sa bas se recharger si
besoin et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dreamy est venu améliorer la charge
ici on a une charge qui est 30 % plus
rapide par rapport aux générations
précédentes un des très gros points fort
ici c'est l'application qui est
extrêmement complète déjà quand vous
arrivez là vous trouvez votre aspirateur
bon si vous en avez d'autres P venir les
piloter indépendamment l'un et l'autre
c'est quand même vachement bien donc
vous allez dans votre appareil ici il y
a plein de choses la première chose
qu'on voit et bien c'est votre
cartographie c'est le plan de la maison
donc moi j'ai mes différentes pièces et
vous voyez le dernier nettoyage qu'il a
fait ici à savoir que vous voyez par
exemple ici il met des petits points il
a vu des objets je clique dessus et là
je vois vois ce que c'est là il me le
montte c'est un espèce de petit pied
qu'il est venu retrouver c'est le pied
d'un tabouret en fait identification
résultat base c'est une base
effectivement après il propose
différentes chosees ilora les obstacles
des commentaires sur les erreurs de
connaissance ici globalement ça marche
donc ça vous allez l' voir dans plein
d'endroits à droite et à gauche
qu'est-ce qu'il a trouvé ici câ
d'alimentation on vient dessus
effectivement au fond il y a un câble
d'alimentation donc ça vous permet de
savoir exactement ce qu'il y avait ce
qui trait dans votre maison à cet
endroit-l maintenant ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que j'ai quelques infos je vois
qu'ici j'ai 36 m² qu'il est venu faire
ça a pris 65 minutes et on est à 99 % de
charge tout de suite j'ai quelques
paramètres en bas qui sont vachement
pratiques j'ai soit le clean genus où je
vais avoir un mode quotidien il va
bienir nettoyer facilement simplement
proprement ok pour le nettoyage
quotidien et puis j'ai un mode ultime le
mode ultime il en fera vachement plus
plus de passage plus en profondeur je
vais vous montrer moi ce que j'ai mis en
place comme stratégie de nettoyage dans
quelques instants vous pouvez venir
personnaliser le nettoyage vous avez vos
paramètres de nettoyage au niveau de
l'aspiration et du lavage ça va être
uniquement un balayage ça ça va être
passer la serpillère là ça va être
l'aspiration et le lavage et là vous
venez choisir passer serpillère après le
balayage comm ça vous choisissez
vraiment ce que vous vous voulez moi je
mets aspiration et lavage après pour
l'aspiration vous choisissez moi je suis
en mode standard vous choisissez en mode
silencieux le mode d'aspiration fort ou
le modeaspiration turbo en fonction de
ce dont vous avez besoin ce que je vous
conseille c'est de le faire passer vous
verrez si vous avez besoin d'en mettre
un peu plus par exemple vous avez des
poiles de chien un peu raid un peu
complexe vous sentez que c'est un peu le
bazarre pour venir pousser la puissance
d'aspiration bon à vous de voir le
passage de la serpillère moi je suis en
mode standard vous pouvez le mettre
passage de la serpillère avec l'économie
d'eau ou alors là carrément en
profondeur moi je me suis mis en mode
serpillère standard ça me va très bien
et puis ensuite vous avez le paramètre
de l'effet de la serpillère qui peut
être personnalisé donc personnaliseer
l'effet vous choisissez spillère
légèrement sèche mouillé ou alors
carrément humide et vous choisissez
ensuite le nettoyage nettoyage quotidien
nettoyage intensif ou nettoyage en
profondeur quotidien ici ça Mira très
très bien donc vous voyez on peut quand
même aller vachement loin on peut
ensuite venir aller sur une séquence de
nettoyage vous lui dites bah j'en sais
rien moi cette pièce tu vas commencer
par là tu vas aller là tu vas finir par
là vous choisissez l'ordre pour faire un
glisser déposé commencz le nettoyage
vous le lancez retour à la station de
base ok fréquence de retour à
l'autonettoyage par zone de 10 m² ça
c'est quand même très très bien parce
que ça veut dire que tous les 10 m carré
vous voyezci il y a 36 m² ça veut dire
que trois fois en fait la serpilière est
venue se renettoyer pour être sûr de
toujours être propre ça sert à rien de
nettoyer un sol avec une serpilière sale
ça ferait pas le taf correctement donc
c'est quand même bien qu'elle revienne
donc vous choisissez ici en fonction de
10 m² 15 m² par zone elle a fini une
zone elle peut revenir à vous de voir
donc ça une fois de plus il y a plein de
paramètres je trouve ça vachement bien
quantité d'eau pour le lavage d'un
tampon donc quand vous allez venir
nettoyer ensuite sur votre base et bien
vous mettez en nettoyage quotidienyage
en profondeur économie d'eau comme ça
c'est vous qui choisissez la quantité
d'eau que vous allez venir injecter donc
là ensuite pour le mode serpillère
séchage progr am 2h 3h 4h vidage
automatique nettoyage quotidien
intelligent basse fréquence bon moi je
le laisse comme ça globalement ça me va
bien mais ce que je trouve vraiment bien
c'est qu'il y a énormément de paramètres
et de possibilités ici pour venir
choisir ce qu'on veut faire réellement
dans son application mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là parce que vous avez ensuite tout
un menu avec plein de choses doncj j'ai
mon historique de nettoyage donc je vois
ce qu'il m'a fait je vois combien de
temps il a mis nettoyage global 36 m² 65
minutes 37 m 66 Minutes enfin gros il
met une petite T pour faire 35 m²r
nettoyage programmé ça c'est le truc qui
m'intéresse moi j'ai programmé trois
types de nettoyage le lundi et je dis en
clean Genius je lui mets tout tu me fais
un nettoyage ultime vous voyez je l'
Miss juste en bas comme ça il nettoie
tout très très très en profondeur bon je
donne des horaires je choisi le jour
etci et ça ça c'est pour le lundi et le
jeudi pour le mardi et le vendredi je
lui dis tu mets un nettoyage quotidien
ça sert à rien que tu aille autant en
profondeur ces jour-là donc je donne un
horaire et si et ça OK et je lu dis par
contre le mercredi et le samedi il y a
du monde à la maison tu vas y aller à
14h un horaire qui nous convient très
très bien et tu passes en mode quotidien
après vous pouvez venir personnaliser si
vous souhaitez vous choisissez les
pièces dans lesqueles il va aller si
vous voulez dire par exemple un jour tu
vas pas tel pi dans une autre c'est
possible les raccourcis qui ont été
définis donc il y a pas mal de petites
choses une fois de plus on peut aller
très très en profondeur ça c'est un truc
que je trouve aussi vachement vachement
vachement bien vous avez les paramètres
de nettoyage de la moquette si vous vous
dites par exemple tiens un jour en
particulier à telle heure tu vas me
faire les tapis et l'autre moment tu vas
me faire ça on peut venir le cinder très
facilement ça dépend une fois de plus de
vous de vos paramètres mais on peut
venir le faire on peut aller très loin
donc ça c'est bien paramètres de
nettoyage des sols exactement la même
chose alors là on peut le dire de venir
nettoyer dans le sens du sol dans le
sens des plaines nettoyer dans un
certain sens si vous avez peur que ça
laisse des traces c'est pour réduire en
fait les les petites très nure au niveau
des joints de sol allez on va venir
l'activer ici réglage de serpillère
intelligent ajou automatiquement le
détergent donc là il va venir doser
directement le détergent qui va venir
mettre démontage installation
automatique des tampons basculement
automatique de la serpilière mode
Intelligent nettoyage quotidien très
fréquent bon vous le laisseer en
intelligent on va faire le taf quand
même deième nettoyage automatique
fonctionne en mode quotidien et en mode
ultime relevage automatique des
lingettes fonctionne uniquement en mode
ultime et après on peut mettre en mode
ultime et quotidien en fait ça vous dit
quoi ça vous dit qu'une fois que la
fonction est activée le robot lavera à
nouveau la lingette si est t qu'elle est
trop sale en mode CAN genénus en fait on
vient totalement optimiser bon ici en
mode ultime ça me paraît mieux parce
qu'il va venir nettoyer beaucoup plus en
profondeur en mode quotidien globalement
ça fera le taf mais si vous voulez le
faire vous pouvez le faire durée
résiduelle donc là vous voyez votre
filtre à quel moment il faut venir les
nettoyer les changer les filtres les
brosses les capteurs le sac à poussière
bref le détergent ça c'est quand même
vachement cool la caméra en temps réel
on peut venir regarder ce qui se passe
en temps réel chez vous directement si
vous voulez l'amplification pour les
grosses particules bon ok on peut venir
mettre si on a besoin tac on va venir
l'activer identification paria donc ça
on vient l'activer par défaut ça l'ai
déjà mis animaux domestiques moi j'ai un
animal je l'ai coché nettoyage
stratégique de la zone autour de
l'animal de compagnie on peut
l'autoriser à vir faire les photos comme
je vous ai montrer ou pas si vous
souhaitez pour des questions de
confidentialité la gestion du robot
verrouillage enfant ça c'est aussi une
bonne option l'évitement des collisions
l'éclairage d'app pointint télécommande
localiser le robot enfin il y a plein de
petites options voie et volume hop là
moi je vais mettre en français parce que
je l'avais laissé en anglais les unités
ici je suis en mètre carré test de
vidange et d'arrivé d'au automatique nom
de l'appareil enfin j'ai pas mal
d'options ici la mise à jour du soft je
peux dire ben tiens va me nettoyer une
pièce en particulier par exemple la
cuisine ou petit salon si je veux pas
qu'il aille partout je peux lui dire va
me nettoyer une zone je peux lui dire
ben tiens par exemple tu viens ici là tu
me fais cette petite zone c'est
largement suffisant et ça m'ira bien et
là je l'envoie après je peux faire des
séquences de nettoyage va nettoyer une
fois deux fois trois fois en fonction
des besoins et je peux après venir
ajouter encore une autre zone dans
laquelle je veux qu'il aille bon si j'ai
besoin ici ça ok why not bon là je
vaisenir les enlever parce que non et
puis ensuite je peux donner des zones
restreinte mettre un mur virtuel si par
exemple il y a un endroit où je ne veux
pas qu'il aille et bien je mets un mur
virtuel je dis là tu vas pas tu passeras
pas une zone interdite au nettoyage bah
là tu vas pas par exemple un endroit où
mon fils laisse plein de jouets que j'ai
pas envie c'est moi qui vais venir
nettoyer je peux lui dire et là où une
zone également interdite au lavage des
sols c'est aussi une possibilité bon
pour l'instant je vais pas le faire mais
voyez je peux venir totalement
personnaliser ça c'est vachement bien le
Dream me L20 Ultra est donc un super
aspirateur pour la maison c'est du
premium c'est du très premium très très
joli produit qui nettoie vraiment super
bien totalement personnalisable dans
l'application vous l'avez vu bref je
vous le recommande s'il vous intéresse
une fois de plus et bien je vous mets un
lien juste en bas la description je vous
invite à venir cliquer pour en savoir
plus et découvrir cet aspirateur encore
plus en profondeur et s'il vous
intéresse pourquoi pas venir l'acheter
parce que réellement cet aspirateur
robot est en super compagnon pour la
maison et il va vous faire gagner un
temps de fou en terme de ménage donc
s'il vous intéresse le lien est en bas
dans la description et merci à Dami
d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo